[Applaudissements]
ce soir il y a des gens qui pensaient
qu'à la voir un débrouiller mais il y a
un gars qui sourit un chef blessé mais
encore debout parti autrefois marginale
maintenant à la croisée des chemins on a
semé de l'espoir
bonjour Je voulais savoir si vous êtes
déjà passé votre partie conservateur du
Québec est né en 2009 dans la plus
grande discrétion et n'a réussi à
franchir la barre du 1 point de
pourcentage de votre populaire que 9 ans
plus tard aux élections de 2018 il y a
beaucoup meilleur que moi
le chef de l'époque avait obtenu près de
9% des voix
la situation financière était très saine
on avait 500 000 dollars en banque pas
de dettes
eric va bien Pouliot avait brigué les
suffrages dans la circonscription de
Chauveau en banlieue de Québec celle où
c'est présenté cette fois son successeur
Eric duham la combinaison de sa
réputation à Québec toute la question de
la pandémie qui était difficile pour
bien des gens je pense que c'était la
bonne personne au bon moment mais je
veux continuer à être la voix de toutes
celles et de tous ceux qui souffrent
énormément présentement de l'extrémiste
sanitaire de François Legault et de
l'incompétence de son gouvernement
bonjour ça va bien oui j'ai toujours été
sous-estimé rappelez-vous qu'au début là
on nous disait que ça lèverait pas on
nous disait qu'on allait avoir 4% après
ceci ça après se dire ça serait ça
aujourd'hui on est rendu en 15 et 20 on
a quand même pas mal monté d'échelle
depuis ce temps-là voilà c'est fait
décentraliser ou juste tout ce qui
propose je trouve que j'avais vraiment
beaucoup de sens je trouve que ces
valeurs et sa manière d'être me
rejoindre plus bonne journée l'ancien
animateur de radio provocateur et
controversé affirme avoir réussi son
premier pari obtenir une reconnaissance
officielle et un succès d'estime
populaire
c'est un peu stressé le son mais pas
nerveux quand on fait campagne mais là
quand on est à 22 minutes très
exactement du dévoilement des résultats
on peut plus rien faire son opposition
au projet de tunnel entre Lévis et
Québec semblent avoir fait mouche sa
philosophie libertarienne incluant une
forte baisse des taxes également on
était le parti qui depuis deux ans et
demi a défendu les libertés
individuelles a défendu les droits
civiques a défendu la démocratie et a
dénoncé les mesures sanitaires abusives
c'est évident que ça fait partie du
paysage on peut pas le nier c'est une
game à long terme c'est un combat
d'idées puis c'était un gros paquebot
faire tourner le Québec là vers la
droite là c'est une grosse affaire mais
les capacités du à faire élire un député
malgré les 600 000 voix obtenues et
difficiles à avaler
les lois électorales on vise le long
terme on est là pour un projet de
société son nom qu'on veut 600 000 la
première un autre 100000 la prochaine
fois ben on va être à la position
les quatre prochaines années vont lui
permettre d'exposer les idées du parti
et puis les Québécois seront seront en
mesure de faire leur choix j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup d'espoir pour 20-26 merci
beaucoup les jeunes si ça me fait
plaisir bonne fin de soirée le défi des
rituels ils sont partis sera d'abord
d'essayer de se faire une place dans les
débats politiques sans avoir été admis à
l'Assemblée nationale